interprétation poétique en musique une
entrée dans l'univers de la poésie pour
tous sans besoin d'études de sémantique
le printemps des poètes vous plonge dans
toutes ses fantaisies cet après-midi-là
atelier vient on va voir des poètes
on propose à tant de scènes ouvertes
voilà chacun vient adultes enfants
adolescents lire un texte qu'il a envie
de lire une vingtaine de lieux sont
investis sur l'ensemble du festival une
quarantaine d'intervenants pour vous
faire aimer la musique du langage des
mots qui partent à l'international et
permet au public saint quentinois un peu
de vagabondage monfils qui a des
origines marchiennes s'est demandé si le
raconter une histoire par les marocains
parce que les prestations de son qu'il a
reconnus du marocain c'est très
inattendu je ne m'attendais pas du tout
à ça et je suis très surprise et très
touché des amoureux de la poésie
passionnés qui vous plonge dans leur
univers inspiré ce que nous proposons
pas menant changement de la musique
et puis l'enchantement des gens qui sont
autour de nous c'est vraiment ce retour
aux origines de cette rencontre entre la
poésie l être humain des rencontres
poétiques sous toutes ses formes la
commanderie accueille le tout premier
village du mot le dernier week-end pour
terminer en grande forme performance
conférences expositions et ateliers vous
pouvez vous le notez en mes mots
[Musique]